hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast delivering on the promise
of personalized molecular medicine
presented by Gordon emails in the PhD
department chair Department of systems
biology division of cancer medicine
University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center we are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by Lavery I'm Julia Zimmer
ahzab Lavery and I'll be your moderator
for today's event labyrinths is relating
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars contribute contributing to
the advancement of science through
content sharing capabilities libraries
is a powerful advocate in amplifying
global networks and communities before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window to click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or introduce the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me in welcoming
dr. Gordon nose I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello it's a
pleasure to be here today to present the
work and project that has been ongoing
at the MD Anderson Cancer Center in the
Zion Institute for personalized cancer
therapy that I co-head with John
Mendelsohn and and supported by fund
America burn Stan and Kenna mill Shaw
we're going to talk today about the
challenges of delivering on the promise
of personalized molecular medicine these
are my potential conflict of interest
disclosures
it is important to note that if we're
going to help our patients we're going
to have to develop a much better and
much more effective academic industrial
partnership and a way to work with
industry so that we can move things
forward in the best manner and the most
effective manner for our patients
now what I'm going to talk about today
is the concept that we finally have the
ability to understand what is happening
in a patient's tumor in a breath and
depth that have never been conceived of
before and as we understand those
changes that happen in a patient's tumor
we have the opportunity to understand
and target those genetic changes to
improve patient outcomes and I want to
point out that this particular concept
applies equally to small molecule
therapy or targeted therapy and also to
immuno oncology and immunotherapy in
particular the key point of this is to
be able to develop appropriate therapies
for the patient that is in front of us
and combine targeted therapies radiation
therapy chemotherapy immunotherapy in
the best way possible if we understand
the tumor sufficiently we should be able
to capitalize on vulnerabilities that
occur in tumor cells because they are
less robust than normal healthy cells
and that has been the underlying
principle of therapy for the last 30
years now I want to start off with a
little bit of a history of how we move
forward in terms of targeted therapies
and this slide is a little bit busy I
actually started this slide many years
ago when there were very few a few
approved targeted therapies but what has
happening has become important is that
we've had many different targeted
therapies of food but all of them to be
effective and useful are late to a
biomarker that is a predictive marker
that identifies patients who are likely
to benefit from that particular targeted
therapy now the first of these stories
started out with the matinee
Maslov and chronic myelogenous leukemia
that was targeting a genomic
translocation called the BCR Abel
translocation it was disappointing that
that particular translocation was
identified in 1982 and it took two into
the 2000s before we got effective
therapy to the patients we do have some
exciting new opportunities coming
forward if you look at the third from
the bottom a particular fusion gene
called AML for elf was identified by a
group in Japan in 2007 it took four
years from identification of that fusion
gene that looked very much like the BCR
Abel translocation to approval of a drug
called president now crizotinib had not
been developed to target AML for elk but
rather was a kinase inhibitor that was
available to target both its original
prediction met and also EML for elk by
off target activity but the excitement
is is that we can match new discoveries
to a large therapeutic toolbox and move
our therapies forward much more quickly
now all of those examples at the top of
the page are those where we think
there's either an aqua gene addiction
that is the oncogene that is present in
the tumor cell is driving the behavior
that tumor and then if we interrupt or
intercept that particular event or
pathway the cells will die because
they've lost their ability to signal
through that pathway now PARP inhibitors
are a very interesting exception and
indeed this is the first effective
approach that we have to target a tumor
suppressor gene or a loss-of-function
abnormality a number of tumors have lost
function of brca1 or brca2 rending them
homologous recombination incompetent and
they makes them synthetically lethal
with inhibition of an additional DNA
damage repair pathway the base excision
repair pathway by Parkin
deters three PARP inhibitors been
approved an ovarian cancer and a
clinical trial has been completed in
breast cancer and we expect approval
very soon in breast cancer now I do want
to point out the two examples down at
the bottom of the page and that is a
bruit nib and tamoxifen or a is a brief
nip is one of the most effective of the
targeted therapies that we have it's
highly active in chronic lymphocytic
leukemia a b-cell leukemia it is
dependent on targeting a molecule called
BTK we actually help define that family
many years ago by cloning its nearest
neighbor called ipk and from that this
became clear that these particular types
of kinases are dependent of determining
lineage dependencies and lineage
survival basically if you want to
survive as a b-cell you have to have BTK
function so what we're targeting with a
group map here is not an oncogenic event
but rather simply a lineage survival
factor that's very similar to what we've
been doing for a very long period of
time in breast cancer in which we target
ER expression as a lineage determinant
with tamoxifen or AIS in that case again
if a cell wants to survive as a luminal
epithelial cell it has to have signaling
through the estrogen receptor and if you
interdict that signaling the cell has no
option but to die and indeed I think we
are going to see more and more examples
of lineage determinants that we can use
as therapeutic opportunities as we move
forward at the MD Anderson Cancer Center
we have a major program in personalized
therapy to attempt to determine what is
the benefit and how best to use these
approaches if the MD Anderson Cancer
Center we see about 20,000 patients a
year do not have a curable option
somewhere between five and nine thousand
of those each year are deemed
to likely benefit from molecular testing
and we do in that number of tests each
year allowing us now to talk about
results from tens of thousands of
patients so that the statistical power
of what I'm going to tell you is very
strong the act we focus on actionable
mutations those aberrations that are
present in the tumor that at the time
the patient presents are driving the
behavior of the tumor particularly those
that are targetable those that we have
drugs that either directly target the
abnormality or indirectly target the
abnormality by affecting pathways that
are altered by the genomic aberration
that is present in the patient's tumor
we do also assess markers that predict
patient outcomes so that we can help
with identifying prognostic markers when
we have a targetable aberration as is
indicated on the left hand side many of
our patients go the standard of care
those drugs that I showed you in the
previous slide we though most frequently
use this information to fill clinical
trial cohorts rapidly and get active
drugs to patients that is move drugs
from clinical trials onto that page that
I showed you have approved drugs that
can be used in standard of care for
patients we also run a number of n of
one trials looking at rare diseases and
rare approaches and I'm going to talk
about those more in a few minutes for
those patients who don't have a target
of elaboration that's about half of our
patients we frequently will go in and do
very deep characterization of what is
happening in their tumor to attempt to
understand what are the driving events
and then also to take that information
and do high throughput biological
validation to determine what we should
do about each of the events that we see
in patients I want to show you some
relatively old data and by the way all
of my data slides will have the name of
the facial he did the work usually in
the lower corner
lower left or lower right hand corner
this was a clinical trial done in the
phase one program at the MD Anderson
Cancer Center with Philip Jenkins lead
what they did was take a large number of
patients all of whom had a single
mutation in pi3 kinase and were then
assessed by that drugs that targeted the
pi3 kinase pathway and what we see
initially is what's exciting in this
waterfall plot at the right hand side
you see a group of patients who had
marked benefit and indeed resist
criteria PR of over 30% which is
extremely unusual in a things warmed
file so this suggested that linking at
pi3 kinase abnormality and the therapy
targeting the pathway had efficacy
that's not the important message though
in this particular slide set the first
is is that we have thought that the co
mutations that occur in two nurse pi3
kinase mutations and mutations in B RAF
or K grass would interact and all of
those that had abnormalities in k rafts
we expected to be non-responsive to a
pi3 kinase inhibitor and indeed as we
initially looked at the data we thought
that was correct as you look at the left
hand side you will see a patient with K
rafts where the tumor grew rapidly the
red bar and then you will see a number
of bowel tumors which are also in red
where there was limited benefit the
tumor was stable or progressed however
as we look more closely in those two
gray bars at the right hand side these
low grade serous ovarian cancer patients
have both b raf and k rafts mutations
and benefited markedly so the message
that comes from that is that the context
of the mutation occurs and indeed if you
look at all of the patients that show
benefit in this particular study they
have variants of women's cancers this is
a cervix cancer on the far right to
endometrial cancers next to it a breast
cancer next and then to ovarian cancers
and for reasons that
we do not completely understand as of
yet pi3 kinase pathway inhibitors even
though you have exactly the same
mutations in all of these patients
tumors appear to be most effective in
this cadre of women's cancers so we're
beginning to see some of the challenges
that we have can we truly achieve
personalized therapy well one of the
first things about the concept of
personalized therapy is that it's an N
of one problem we want to treat every
individual based on exactly what is
happening in their tumor we're going to
have a separate treatment for every
patient that is intractable both in
terms of how we would deal with the FDA
and approval process and the costs of
having separate medicines for each
individual what we are probably looking
more at is what we call precision
medicine treating each patient in a much
more precise manner based on what is
happening in their tumor another way of
looking at that is calling it stratified
medicine that is instead of treating a
disease as a single group we split the
disease into many different groups that
are more and more homogeneous and
getting more effective therapy now that
has its own problem ductal breast cancer
is noted here is the most common of all
cancers in women and we've separated
that into at least eight therapeutically
relevant subclasses
unfortunately this takes a very common
disease that is easy to do clinical
trials in and create a set of orphan
diseases where it is very difficult to
complete trials in some of the rarer
subgroups indeed one of the rarer
subgroups metaplastic breast cancer that
we work on extensively is chock-full of
aberrations for which we have targeted
therapies but it has been very hard to
mount clinical trials to test those
hypotheses because it is a relatively
rare disease we also have a similar
problem as we look at the abnormalities
that are present in tumors
aka part of that pi3 kinase pathway that
I mentioned previously is mutated in
tumors and I'm going to talk about it
more detail in a few moments but the
most frequent aberrations are in two to
three percent of any major tumor lineage
and somewhere around 1% in clinical
trial sets this makes it very difficult
to mount clinical trials to test the
hypothesis that targeting akp would be
effective for particular populations of
played patients one of the things that
we do to help fill those trials with
rare aberrations is to do multiplex
analysis of multiple different
aberrations across a patient's tumor
which will allow amortization of the
cross of the cost of that testing across
multiple trials and indeed going from
testing one or two genes to testing
several hundred genes does not markedly
increase the cost of the project now
we've had a large program at the NV
Anderson Cancer Center called Clearing
House we have now registered over 12,000
patients better than 6,000 that are
mention this particular slide we
obtained a tissue block from the patient
we do a new biopsy if it's clinically
indicated or part of a trial and we then
test that tumor in our Cleo laboratory
in pathology and lab medicine we've used
multiple different testing platforms
going from a 50 gene hot spot analysis
to a 400 gene filling sequencing and now
a u.s. wide project called all combined
that is part of the NCI match trial and
what's important is is that for all of
those patients who have actionable
events we carefully follow what happens
for that patient and the temp to
understand why those patients do or do
not receive particular therapies and
whether they do or do not help patient
outcomes in addition we can characterize
the patients deeply in our research
laboratory and following CLIA
confirmation use that to help monitor
and help
for patient outcomes over the last five
years we have been covering the cost of
this program through philanthropy and
unfortunately that is a non sustainable
approach and today
reimbursement for the clinical testing
that is required to direct patients on
the clinic clinical trials and through a
personalized medicine program is
sporadic aliy reimbursed and frequently
not reimbursed to the full cost of the
tests that are done so one of the key
problems that we have and that are
across the whole field is to convince
payers that this has benefit to patients
and further that they should then pay
for all of the testing that is required
not just when the patient starts their
therapy but over time as their tumors
may evolve I want to show you some data
from the first 19,000 patients that
we've analyzed this is a vignette of
2,000 patients where we have done
extensive testing here looking at the
majority of the genes that are important
in cancer we find in this particular
study that about 40% of patients have a
potentially actionable event those are
indicated down at the bottom by a blue
arrow but when we look at the frequency
of particular mutations starting with
the highest on the left-hand side which
is p53 we look as we go down that curve
and find very rapidly the mutational
events become quite rare and indeed
beyond the first 10 most common events
all of them are under 1% across our
population of patients that means that
it is very difficult to identify those
patients and also to develop clinical
trials to test the hypothesis that
targeting those abnormalities would be
effective and and improve patient
outcomes
indeed this challenge of rare
aberrational aberrations and tumors is a
second of our major problems to deal
with in
lamenting personalized cancer therapy
now I mentioned that I would come back
to a Katy this is a figure from patients
with endometrial cancer who benefited
markedly from an akt inhibitor based on
them having an mutation in a Katie that
activated a Katie and rendered the tumor
responsive to a Katie targeted drugs now
this is a significant opportunity in
that about 1% of patients will have no
abnormalities in this particular game
and we could match those to a targeted
agent that is highly affected however
the cost of doing this becomes almost
prohibitive if you work for example to
want 50 patients on a trial only about
half of the patients that are tested
positive for the abnormality would be
eligible due to performance status or
other challenges you're going to be
testing about 5000 patients at 3,000
dollars per patient or 15 million
dollars just to find the patients to
enter on the trial prior to being able
to do the trial and also having to deal
with the charges and costs of running
the trial itself and that has become
prohibitive now one of the ways in which
we've dealt with this and industry is
dealing with it is asking us to test
broadly all of those blue arrows and
after you do that testing direct
patients to trials that fit their
particular abnormality well this is
cost-effective in into industry in an
institution that has to cover the cost
of the testing until such time as it
becomes reimbursable by payers this has
been a significant problem and a
significant challenge now one of the
biggest problems that we have with
targeted therapy basically problem
number three is that our therapeutic
indexes are limiting that is when we
treat patients we target not just the
mutant abnormality but we target the
normal gene from which the mutation is
derived and in the cell normal genes
have a
that is why they are there and in most
cases the drugs that we use target both
the wild type and the mutant there is
one exception today which is idh1 where
we do have an inhibitor that is specific
to the neo morphic function of mutant
idh1 and that is highly effective with
limited toxicity as you look at those
arrows on the left hand side in red you
can see abnormalities that occur
frequently enough that is a single
abnormality in those genes is at a
present level that we could develop a
clinical trial in a series of targeted
agents and indeed we've been able to
show that we can develop targeted
therapy for particular mutations in
pik3ca I mentioned the idh1 there's
evidence for inhibitors that will target
specific abnormalities and k rafts these
agents are expected to have a much
higher therapeutic index than our
current targeted therapies and may thus
have a much greater efficacy now here is
what I want to show you for some of our
major challenges on our first 2,000
patients we place 2,000 patients under
genetic testing and we assess potential
actionable mutations we found 789
potentially actionable events and then
asked what happens with those patients
despite the patients being enrolled on a
clinical trial where they said they
wanted to have genetic testing and have
drugs that related to the genomic events
only 83 of the patients that we started
with went on a clinical trial that used
the data from the genomic testing that
was 4% of patients this is really a very
disappointing observation when we split
that up we found that the number of
those trials didn't require the
abnormality that we found for entry into
the trial that was 54 patients when we
looked there were a number of patients
that received drugs that were related to
the abnormality in there too
it was another twenty nine patients but
really this was a very small return on a
massive investment in terms of testing
2,000 patients now if we ask what
percentage of patients who have
abnormalities when on a clinical trial
its 11 percent and that's a reasonable
number but clearly not justifying where
we were this is what you see across the
community and indeed these numbers are
completely representative of what has
been reported by almost all of the major
centers entering into a genomic testing
program we took a look at this and said
we had to evaluate carefully why this
was happening instead of goal of having
at least 25% of our patients that went
underwent testing entering on clinical
trials so we have succeeded in that but
what I want to show you is some of the
things that we found the first one is is
when we did testing we found about 40%
of our patients to have a mutation in an
actionable gene that was the number that
I told you earlier the rest of our
patients we did not have an opportunity
with the testing that we were doing and
one of the questions we asked is what
would happen if we markedly increased
the scope of our testing from a series
of candidate genes to a much larger
number of genes and when we did that we
did indeed increase the number of
patients with potentially actual
mutations but only to 54 percent so
although we were able to increase the
numbers it was not a marked increase and
further in many of those cases it was
not absolutely clear that these events
were actionable they were mutations that
could have been passengers that is
mutations that happen due to genomic
instability in the tumor rather than
those that were driving the behavior of
the tumor that targeting those would be
beneficial to patients so we then went
in and asked what happened carefully
with the nut with our patients where we
had very clear targeted therapies
available and these are those targeting
the pi3 kinase pathway that I've
mentioned or b-raf mutations indeed one
of the first thing we found is is that
only about half of the patients that we
went entered into our trial at further
treatment at the MD Anderson Cancer
Center many of them simply did not
return some had poor performance
performance status some decided to go
elsewhere
and others we were unable to understand
why they fail to have treatment but it
was very clear that only about half of
our patients had further treatment at
our Center so we've taken that into
careful consideration and done a much
more effective job of querying our
patients as to what they would like to
do if they had positive results from a
clinical test and how that would
influence our ability to reach our 25
percent success rate indeed when we
looked at this much more carefully we
found that of those patients who went on
trials at the MD Anderson Cancer Center
with these particular abnormalities 40%
of those actually did receive a genotype
match drug that is if you had an
aberration in this particular group of
genes and if you receive through their
therapy over 40% of those patients
actually benefited from the testing that
was being done so that left us with an
opportunity to really become much closer
to that 25% goal so what have we learned
well first increasing the scope of
testing only increases actionable
aberrations slightly we need more
effective drugs and it's important that
we have more drugs available for our
clinical trials and indeed we make a
mistake of not counting that whole
population of patients who go on
standard of care drugs we only were
looking at those that went on clinical
trials and this markedly underestimated
the value of our treatment program we
also needed to have a process to deal
with these rare actionable advanced
across tumors and we set up a series of
bucket
to deal with these things such as a K T
and T R K we also found that there is a
challenge with tumor heterogeneity and
therapy induced evolution and I'm going
to talk about that later one of the big
things though and probably the biggest
of the whole process is that many of our
physicians were not comfortable using
the information that was being provided
from the molecular testing and so we
have set up a molecular tumor board a
clinical trial alert that tells the
patient the physician that their patient
has a clinical trial that matches with
their aberrations and also have
established a major decision support
program that I'm going to talk about in
more detail in a few moments I've
already mentioned these other points one
important one to bring forward is that
testing itself attracts high quality
information rich trials in patients and
institutions should consider whether
they want to consider the cost of
testing a loss leader to increase their
market penetrants and to bring in trials
that are going to be beneficial for
their patients so one of the things that
we did do is go in and ask what was
happening in terms of patient testing if
we added this standard of care that is
moving patients to drugs that had
already been approved but needed genomic
testing for entry and indeed what we
found was that other patients that went
on trials we had only been focusing on
this clinical trial group which was at
58% but we found that 36% of our
patients with positive results did
receive standard of care for drugs that
were effective and surprising to us a
number of patients received drugs
off-label and likely benefit from that
use so actually the benefit on our
studies were much higher than we had
predicted from our initial analysis now
one of the key challenges that we have
is as we move into an era of targeted
therapy and molecular tests
it is impossible for anyone to
understand the complete complexity and
all of the potential opportunities that
arise as one test patients so we have
had to build a medical decision support
program and as I mentioned earlier it is
one of the major reasons why we increase
the success of our program one of the
biggest challenges that we have in this
decision support is that there are many
aberrations that we find and we do not
know whether they are drivers or
passengers that is a driver is a genomic
event that causes the tumor to behave
inappropriately at the time the patient
presents and the passenger is those that
happen due to genomic instability so we
have developed a major program that we
feed into our physician decision support
program in which we characterize several
hundred mutations in particular genes or
uncle genes each month for their
functional effects and what we would do
in terms of targeting those
abnormalities and this has been funded
by the CT d squared program of the
National Cancer Institute so we
integrate that with our information this
shows you where the problem is we have
over a million aberrations that have
been identified in patients tumors and
under a thousand of them have been
functionally annotated so we have this
major problem of many or most of the
mutations that we identify in patients
we do not know whether they are going to
be a driver or passenger there are now
over 20 different algorithms or programs
to attempt to identify whether a new
aberration is a driver or a passenger
and simply stating that there are 20
different approaches indicates that none
of them work well so this functional
annotation is critical and one of the
comments that I noted earlier is that
some mutations are very important and
this is that idh1 and ID h2 mutation and
it changes the function of the gene
because of that you have to change the
particular drug that you use
this is a very important concept in that
if you were to use a drug targeting the
parental idh1 and only partially block
idh1 you may actually make the outcome
of a patient with an idh1 mutation worse
because it is a different functional
mechanism than that of the parental
molecule these are called neo morphs and
are going to be critical to make this
happen as I mentioned earlier we have
set up a broad-based program to identify
the characteristics of these aberrations
and we make this information available
to our faculty in real time we do not
use this to manage particular patients
in front of us but rather to develop a
catalog of aberrations that we can use
to manage patients throughout their
course of care now our personalized
cancer website is identified here and
you can find it just by looking at
personalized cancer therapy and the MD
Anderson Cancer Center or you can look
pull it up from https PCT MD Anderson
org we have annotated fully 27 genes and
that is over 90% of all of the
aberrations that one will find in cancer
that's due to the fact that we annotated
all of the commonly mutated genes and
left out those very long tails we've
annotated them for all abnormalities
that we can detect the physician is able
to determine the level of information
that they want going anywhere from you
should treat this patient with a
particular drug on a trial going down to
the paper that says why this is the case
we also very importantly provide a level
of evidence for each recommendation that
we suggest we also provide where
clinical trials are available with a
heavy emphasis on making sure that all
of the trials available to MD Anderson
Cancer Center X date now one of the
things that we've done with that
decision support program is to ask
whether that will improve the number of
patient that goes on clinical
miles misses our most recent trial where
we tested patience deeply approximately
400 patients were entered on the trial
and just over half of them had a variant
in an actionable gene and importantly we
reached our goal of 25% with mutations
and actionable genes being enrolled on
clinical trials we actually may be doing
much better than that in that at least
12% of our patients have not proceeded
throughout their clinical care far
enough where they would be eligible for
entry on to those trials so we do expect
those numbers to improve and we were a
little bit disappointed in that we had a
number of abnormalities in patients
tumors where we did not think these were
drivers we call them variants of unknown
significance and many physicians still
enrolled them on clinical trials as if
these were driver aberrations and indeed
when we queried our physicians they said
that those trials were as useful or
likely to be useful as any other trial
that was available to a patient and it
certainly was not likely to cause bones
or harm the exciting observation is that
despite the fact that this was a very
early trial we saw a marked benefit for
the patients who had a matching drug any
matching therapy the line in blue at the
bottom is those patients who did not
have an abnormality or did not have a
match drug and they did not do well but
those at the top of had an abnormality
and a match therapy did much better and
indeed in a Phase one program to see
over half of the patients still alive at
18 months is truly a homerun and a
remarkable outcome that should be
convincing payers that this is indeed
beneficial to our patients now one of
the problems as we go forward in
broad-based testing is that although we
test the patient's tumor we find
information that is present in their
germline and inheritable germline
aberrations not only influence the
patient's in front of us but influence
their family
and so what are we going to do with this
particular information what if you find
an abnormality in brca1 or brca2 or p53
where this has a marked impact and what
will happen on it on their family also
some others that are really low risk
variants or rare variants such as those
in FGFR where again it is not clear what
you would do with that information so we
tested germline variants in a thousand
patients and found that 99% of those
patients requested return of results
even though these results can influence
their family quite broadly and they were
concerned about their own cancer they
wanted to know what was going on that
could have contributed to development of
their cancer we thought that this might
be a major problem finding many
aberrations that would overwhelm our
genetic counselors who help patients
deal with their family and family
history it turned out that that was not
the case in the 19 genes that are
recommended for testing by the clinical
testing groups we found 43 germline
mutations and a thousand patients with
advanced cancer 19 or sorry 20 of those
had already been identified and the
patient knew they were in their family
most of those were brca1 and brca2
breast cancer woman breast cancer 2 here
in red one very big surprising
observation that we had were
abnormalities in p53 p53 is the cause of
the lead from any syndrome and we
thought it was highly penetrant however
it turned out we identified a number of
individuals who had inherited
abnormalities in p53 in the same
location as those in the leaf for many
syndrome and they had not developed any
evidence of a leaf remaining syndrome in
their family we have now worked with
colleagues from multiple centers and
have found that this is indeed a general
observation and we are trying to
understand what this means in terms of
the impact of p53 mutations in the pace
Jeremih now one of the challenges that
we have moving forward is that although
our patients respond and those with a
biomarker benefit the responses are
usually short-term and that's because
resistance is almost universal and one
of the biggest concerns that has come
forward in the last several years is
that heterogeneity will be a major
challenge that will prevent us from
fulfilling the promise of personalized
cancer medicine if we look at where
mutations happen in a tumor those that
are in solid markers at the top of the
pathways are frequently mutated whereas
those towards the bottom of the pathway
are rarely mutated indeed if we look at
a functionally vantur a systems biology
concept almost all of the mutations that
we find at the surface of cells or in
proteins at the surface of cells
integrate to a very limited number of
downstream effectors pathways and that
means that it is possible that
convergent evolution or activation of
similar pathways may allow us to deal
with the heterogeneity that is present
in tumors we explore this extensively by
studying what is happening in proteins
and protein signaling and draya Califano
has a major programme looking at RNA as
a readout for what is happening in
protein pathways now this is the
original paper in the New England
Journal of Medicine that suggested that
intramural heterogeneity was going to be
a major problem in targeted therapy and
personalized medicine and indeed when
this paper came out many of my
colleagues and patients said that this
could be the death knell for targeted
therapy altogether and that there were
so many different variations in both the
primary tumor and then the metastasis
and what you can see here in blue are
all of the in gray and blue or all of
the different mutations that are present
in different regions of primary
metastatic to
what has they looked at in detail my
auntie katrell and others that were part
of this original paper is that tumors
appear to have a trunk and branch format
you can see on both of these renal cell
carcinomas that were presented in those
two paper that there is a major trunk in
blue which has an abnormality in pH L
which is common in renal cell carcinoma
you also see that all of the metastases
present in those batches have different
mutations and there are indeed many
differences in the metastasis from the
primary tumor however when we look at
this more closely there's an important
observation that I think was missed in
the original paper and is actually very
exciting in terms of the potential
success of targeted therapies so what
you find is is that as one looks at each
one of these branches they have a common
set of aberrations the patient on the
left in every branch has an abnormality
in set E - with an error arrow in red or
in a very similar or related molecule
KDM SC in blue what happened here was
three separate branches of evolution in
this tumor acquired different
abnormalities in set B - suggesting that
once you had a VHL mutation there was an
incredibly powerful Selective pressure
to bring in a set d2 mutation for this
tumor to progress and as we look at the
tumor on the right side we see the same
thing happening the HL on the trunk and
a set d2 mutation different one in each
case on every branch of the tumor and
further similar abnormalities in p10 or
the pi3-kinase pathway in multiple
branches once again indicating that
there is a very strong selective
pressure for these abnormalities to
happen
we've indeed gone in and looked deeply
at patients with breast can
answer with primer in metastasis then
find that over 85% of the time there are
no significant abnormalities that are
targetable between the different primary
and metastasis no do note that doesn't
mean there aren't many other aberrations
but rather that those driver events that
I pointed out earlier are common across
most of the tumor this 85 percent
concordance means that about 15 percent
of tumors will have different ever
aberrations in the primary in the
metastasis and it is important to
understand that this is a study from
another group that looked at primary and
recurrent breast cancers and asked what
were the difference and remarkable in
those particular cases the only
significant aberration that they found
in these tumors was an increased
frequency of mutations in the metastasis
of estrogen receptor mutations indeed
all of these patients had received
estrogen receptor targeted therapy and
that was the driver that selected and
probably caused the aberrations in the
estrogen receptor and indeed go back to
the comment that I made early on that
lineage specific targets are likely to
be high quality targets now this leaves
us with a problem of having to try and
understand what is happening not only in
the primary tumor in the patient but in
the metastasis and it is impossible to
biopsy every metastasis that is present
in a patient one of the most exciting
observations of the last several years
in terms of targeted therapy is that
liquid biopsies have come to the fore
where we can look at circulating DNA DNA
that is released from the tumor into the
circulation and capture most of the
information that is present in terms of
mutations throughout the body indeed
this integrates all of the information
from the primary and the metastatic
tumors we've done studies here at the MD
Anderson Cancer Center headed by Philip
Janko and
found a remarkable concordance between
what you find in the circulating DNA and
in the solid tumor with over 85 87
percent concordance and this is what we
would expect with the heterogeneity that
I mentioned earlier of 85% of lesions
having the same abnormality and 15
percent having discordant C's so we
think this is an accurate representation
of what is going on and indeed we are
moving that into our clinical management
of patients you can detect actionable
aberrations in metastatic cancer you can
monitor response to ask if the mutation
pattern is changing with therapy you can
look for acquired resistance mechanisms
by the targeted therapy and it may be
better than looking at the primary tumor
because you captured all of the
metastatic events across the body there
are opportunities in early detection all
those those are very premature at this
point in time it is exciting to consider
the opportunity to monitor response to
therapy and also determining whether a
patient has benefited markedly from that
therapy allowing us to either stop
therapy if they're doing extremely well
or change therapy if a new aberration is
arising I'd like to thank the people in
my laboratory that have contributed to
the work on the left hand side and to
reinstitute for molecular markers or the
center for molecular markers and the
Institute for personalized cancer
therapy on the right side and people
that we collaborate from around the
world to make these opportunity possible
for our patients thank you thank you dr.
Mills for that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have
for so let's get started our first
question is dr. Mills you've argued that
it's going to be difficult to deliver
personalized molecular medicine what are
the key next steps in this process the
most important next steps in this
process is to have a better pattern or
better set of effective drugs so far our
targeted therapies have been used
primarily as single agents mono therapy
and we have learned over generations of
experience that targeted their single
therapies are likely or not very likely
to be effective in complex diseases such
as epithelial cancers indeed we've
needed to combine chemo radiation
multiple chemotherapy agents to have
marked responses in our patients with
epithelial tumors therefore one of the
key next steps is going to be the
development of rationale combinations of
targeted therapies that overcome
resistance that seems to be inevitable
for most of our patients great thank you
so much for that answer we're going to
wrap up with one more question and that
question is does personalized medicine
include immuno oncology to take the
concepts here that all types of
therapies that we use for our patients
need to be better personalized even the
chemotherapy and radiation therapy that
we use need to be targeted to those
individuals who are most likely to
benefit and that will then justify the
toxicity of those particular therapies
the same applies as we move into the era
of targeted therapy and immunotherapy we
should be thinking of treating our
patients with the best combination of
all of these agents for that particular
individual indeed we already know that
several of our target
therapy's potentiate the effects of
immunotherapy and immunotherapy
potentiates the effects of a number of
our targeted therapies so we need to
think of a concept of therapy and not
focus on whether this is a particular
modality and use the appropriate
combination of radiation chemo surgery
and immunotherapy and targeted therapies
for each individual that we see in the
clinic thank you thank you dr. Mills do
you have any final thoughts appreciate
your listening to the talk I think that
we have an incredible opportunity to
help our patients and that this is going
to be one of the very exciting eras that
we've had where we have more
opportunities more drugs and more
chances to make a difference for
individuals than we have ever had before
thank you for your attention I would
like to once again thank dr. Mills for
his presentation I would also like to
thank leverage for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2017
you will receive an email from Lavery's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye
you